so we have this function f of x
expressed as a rational expression here
or defined with a rational expression
and we're told that each of the
following values of x select whether f
has a zero a vertical asymptote or or a
removable discontinuity and before even
looking at the choices what i'm going to
do because you're not always going to
have these choices here sometimes you
might just have to identify the vertical
asymptotes or the zeros or the removable
discontinuities
is i'm going to factor this out and
hopefully or i'm going to factor the
numerator and the denominator to
hopefully make things a little bit more
clear and we're going to think about
what x values make the numerator and or
the denominator equal to 0.
so the numerator can i factor that
well let's see what two numbers their
product is negative 24 and they add to
negative 2. let's see that would be
negative
6 and positive
4.
so we could write x
minus 6 times x plus 4 did i do that
right negative 6 times 4 is negative 24
negative 6x plus 4x is negative 2x yep
that's right
all right
and now in the denominator
let's see 6 times 4 is 24 6 plus 4 is
10. so we could say
6x plus 6
times x plus 4.
so let's look at the numerator first the
numerator
numerator
0
if
x is equal to
positive 6
or
x is equal to negative 4.
the denominator
denominator is 0
if x is equal to
negative 6
or
x is equal to negative 4.
so
let's think about it can we can we
simplify this what we have up here a
little bit
and i and we're just gonna keep in mind
what i just wrote down well it might be
just you know jumping out at you you
have an x plus 4 divided by an x before
why can't we simplify this expression a
little bit and just write this whole
thing
write our original
original expression as being x minus 6
over x plus 6
where x if we want to be algebraically
equivalent we have to constrain
constrain the domain where x cannot be
equal to negative 4.
well this is interesting because before
when x equals negative 4 we had all this
weird zero over zero stuff but we were
able to remove it and we were able to
make it just kind of this extra
condition and if you were to graph it it
would show up as a little bit of a
removable discontinuity a little bit of
a point discontinuity it's just one
point where the function is not actually
is actually not defined
so in this situation
and this is typical where there's a
thing that
you can factor out it was making the
numerator and the denominator equals 0
but you can factor that out so it no
longer does it that's going to be a
removable discontinuity so x equals
negative 4 is a removable discontinuity
and once you've factored out all the
things that would make it a removable
discontinuity then you can think about
what's going to be a zero and what's
going to be a vertical asymptote if it
makes once you've factored out
everything that's common to the
numerator and the denominator if of
what's left something makes the
numerator equal to zero well then it's
going to make this whole
expression equal to 0 and so you're
dealing with a 0. so at x equals 6
6 would make the numerator equal to 0. 6
minus 6 is 0.
so there you're dealing with a 0
and to make the denominator equal to
zero you get x equals negative six that
would make the denominator equal zero so
that's a vertical
that's a vertical asymptote and it's
called a vertical asymptote because as
you approach this values approach
negative six either from values smaller
than negative six or larger than
negative six the denominator is going to
become either very very
a very it's either going to become a
very very very small positive number or
a very very small negative number it's
going to approach zero either from above
or below and so when you divide by that
you're going to get very large positive
values or very large negative values and
so your graph
your graph does stuff like that
so you have a vertical
you have a vertical asymptote it might
either do something like that or it
might do something it might do something
like this where this is your vertical
asymptote and then when you approach
from here goes bumps up like that so
either way so that's why that's a
vertical asymptote let's do another one
all right
so same drill
and like before and
always pause the video and see if you
can work it out on your own
let me factor it
so let's see two numbers the product is
negative 32 they're gonna have to have
different signs eight and four
and then we want the larger one to be
positive since they have to add up to
positive four x
so
x plus eight
times x minus four yep i think that's
right
and then divided by
this is 4 times 4 is 16
4 negative 4 plus negative 4 is negative
8. so this is
x minus 4 times x minus 4.
now this is really really interesting
because you might say oh i have an x
minus 4 x minus 4 maybe x equals 4 is a
removable discontinuity
and it would have been unless you had if
you didn't have this over here because x
equals 4 even after you factor this you
still can't it's the f the expression
the function is still not going to be
defined when x equals 4. and so this
this function is actually equivalent to
x plus 8 over x minus 4. i don't have to
put that that extra little constraint
like i did before i don't have to put
i don't have to put this little
constraint that describes this removable
discontinuity because that constraint is
still there after i've factored out
after i've canceled out this x minus 4
with this x minus 4. and so here we've
we've this this is actually an
algebraically equivalent expression to
this one right over here and so now we
can think about what the what the zeros
or the vertical asymptotes or the
removable discontinuities are going to
be
well something that makes the numerator
zero without doing it to the denominator
is going to be a zero and x equals
negative eight makes the numerator equal
to zero without doing anything to the
without making the denominator equal to
zero
it would make the denominator equal to
negative 12. so you can literally just
evaluate h of negative 8 is equal to 0
over negative 12
which is equal to which is equal to 0.
so that's why we call it a 0. what about
x equals 4 well x equals 4 is going to
make the denominator
only equal to 0 and so that's going to
give us a vertical asymptote
and we're all done